[Music]
hello and welcome to my neurons myself
not my neurons of course and not myself
I oh my goodness look at all these
selves out here look at you look at all
these cells and I suspect that each one
of you would probably say that you are a
self just like earlier you'd claim at
least you're as much of a self as I am
that's my guess anyway all these selves
well whatever self means whatever self
is this is this is making me perhaps a
little self-conscious and you may be too
whatever self means whatever conscious
means much less consciousness means
whatever means means it's it's so hard
to describe these things lists so
therefore before we start a couple of
basics about our type our title my
neurons myself a neuron it turns out is
not only a brain cell as many of us had
thought until we looked it up but a
nerve cell anywhere in the body arms
legs the spine that is somehow linked to
the 86 billion neurons that are packed
into the brain that's the latest close
estimate 86 billion neurons packed into
the brain inside the skull and the
neural network which links up those
cells in the brain is astonishingly
similar as you can see here to the
recently discovered networks of billions
of galaxies which are the latest
discovery by the astronomers and
physicists of the overall structure of
the universe the galaxies seemed to line
up in the same kind of filigree network
that our brain cells and their
connections seem to and there are
already some serious articles in
scientific journals that suggest this
may not be a coincidence but possibly
they're exploring whether it shows a
common pattern of forces shaping things
great and small galaxies like neurons so
to speak but this is new information and
of course there's an enormous amount of
skepticism coming from all angles about
whether there it is
coincidence or not whether we are just
each a proton and brain of some oath
sitting under another tree dr. Zeus has
been there and a lot of other thinkers
have as well who knows secondly a quick
word about the nature of words
themselves we want to get every detail
in the nature of words themselves
especially the words that may have
attracted you to this program such as
neurons self memory what is memory soul
soul you must have thought about that
emotion mind what is the mind
consciousness scientists and
philosophers have been pointing out for
a long time that just because we've got
a word for something doesn't necessarily
mean there's anything there including
self consciousness for example we may
feel we know what a word means and use
it freely and even use it very well but
it doesn't necessarily mean that there's
anything there but each word has been
evolving in its usage for centuries and
our human ability to constantly change
and create their meanings well we have
to keep that in mind so to speak we have
constantly reminders we have to consume
einde ourselves about the fact that
words themselves don't necessarily tell
us about something that's there as our
panelists use words here this evening
and gestures and emotions probably to
try to enlighten us so to put this all
into perspective though it may give us a
headache or blow our minds at some point
so to speak I wonder what that means
some of these neuroanatomists may have
ideas about that to put this into
perspective we spoke to dr. George
Macari who directs the Institute for the
history of psychiatry for the past 20
years I believe at Weill Cornell he
points out that we often tend to think
of the mind as a natural even a
biological part of who we are but he
says this is actually a relatively
modern concept he has written a book
about the history of these words and
ideas and about how the rise of brain
science in recent days and recent
centuries has helped the modern world to
emerge
from the old medieval world let's take a
look in the medieval world there were
two things body and soul the soul was
the not of the universe because it
integrated belief in God
cosmology life on Earth psychology the
difference between life and death all of
those things that started to crack with
a scientific revolution the world
started to change historian and
psychiatrist George Maharis new book is
called soul machine the invention of the
modern mind the third entity the mind
started to emerge as a natural
alternative for the place for inner life
in the 1500s notions of a secular mind
were already lurking johann vyr of
holland dared to suggested the Church
Fathers that not all witches should be
burned at the stake
because some of them might not have made
covenant with the devil but just be
suffering from a disease that crippled
their reasoning in the 1600s oxford
medical doctor Thomas Willis began
dissecting and mapping the brain
launching modern neuroscience in the
West and his most famous student
philosopher John Locke developed a
science-based theory of mine and of self
that said they were based partly on
imperfect subjective impressions the
mind was highly scandalous very
dangerous as an idea and was one that
very much had a lot of political and
scientific medical and theological
implications that made it quite
explosive why it challenged absolutism
both in terms of political power and in
terms of clerical power the mind was
fallible it could not make absolute
claims about truth it demanded therefore
tolerance because if I can't know the
absolute truth
I should tolerate you and you should
tolerate me it allowed for secular
ethics like life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
[Music]
the idea of a center of Reason and will
that was not immortal caught on and says
Macari helped change the way the West
was run it's the centerpiece of the
emergence of secular culture but there
was a problem could you locate this new
sort of mind in the brain well the brain
is easy to define I mean you can make
the cut where you want but the brain is
an empirical object the problem is
interior experience and mind is not like
any other object in the natural world
because it's not available to the
external observer
and always available to us today we have
technologies that can amaze us with new
discoveries of how some parts of the
brain work and are connected what we
don't have yet I would argue is a way of
bridging mental experience with the
brain in a coherent model that allows
for mental intention and so I would say
we still are a ways off from solving the
mind brain problem evolving concepts of
mind and self spurred by scientific
explorations have helped to change how
societies are governed basing our hopes
more on the real world the exciting
question now is whether our dazzling new
technology can help us understand what
we're really talking about when we speak
of the mind the self and even perhaps
the soul and dr. George Macari is in the
audience tonight if you have questions
afterwards he and some of our other
panelists will be able to stay around
and talk in the in the in the lobby
afterwards so let's get down to business
tonight we're going to be talking with
four scientists and philosophers all in
one way or another working on the
cutting edge of neuroscience of
psychology and philosophy to help us
understand some of the latest thinking
on the self and consciousness our first
participant is a neuroscientist and the
head of Yale's brain function laboratory
one of the early adopters of functional
magnetic resonance and
she is now pioneering the use of
near-infrared spectroscopy to study the
brains of two humans as they interact
please welcome joy hers my chair
actually we're working out our neural
connections our next guest is a
neuroscientist and professor in the
Department of Psychology at the Zukerman
Brian mind brain behavior Institute at
Columbia University her work has yielded
insights into how the brain changes with
learning how memories are created and
retrieved and how memory shapes our
decisions our actions and ourselves
please welcome death Michelle honey
[Music]
also joining us is a Nero ethicist at
the University of Pennsylvania
a former Guggenheim Fellow and recipient
of the Association for psychological
sciences Lifetime Achievement Award
she's currently studying the way
neuroscience is changing how we think of
ourselves as physical mental and moral
beings please welcome Martha Farah and
[Music]
our fourth participant is a philosopher
from the City University of New York and
a leader in the growing field of
experimental philosophy which brings
empirical methods to bear on
philosophical questions he's the author
of several books including furnishing
the mind gut reactions and the emotional
construction of morals
please welcome Jesse Prince so let's
take a look at how one new technology is
advancing our understanding of the brain
and helping us to look for new ways to
approach consciousness in your work joy
you're asking whether there is a
neurobiology of collective consciousness
consciousness tell us what your
experiments aim to do so so just to
start with the last three decades of
neuroscience particularly systems
neuroscience where we try to understand
the workings of the brain by putting
people in scanners and watching the
brain respond has really been dominated
by techniques like functional magnetic
resonance imaging for example and these
are wonderful technologies that have
taught us a great deal about principles
of neural organization but the one
really important function that we never
can connect with or understand with this
technology is the most important
function I think of all of us as humans
and that is how we connect to each other
so that we as social beings looking and
talking to each other are never studied
in the
conventional magnetic resonance imaging
or imaging techniques that that we have
available to us so one of the frontiers
that's been lurking for a long time has
been the frontier of how in the world
are we going to understand what goes on
in the human brain when two people are
in front of each other looking at each
other talking with each other and
interacting in a social way so enter a
new technology and this new technology
see I get to your trusted leader it this
new technology allows us to put what we
call op Toad's on people's heads we
don't have to put people in the scanner
and we can actually use reflectance do
you want me to explain what this is is
that gonna be your next question light
goes in right oh yes okay I'm glad you
asked that question
there's no fMRI but the next stage oh
okay okay okay there's a picture here
okay this is terrific so these are two
people that are set up in a
near-infrared spectroscopy situation
know that you can see they have these
little things on their heads we call
them op toads and what a little op toad
is is a little laser emitter so it emits
a wavelength of light you know if you
take a flashlight you just shine it and
your your finger and you kind of see it
diffuse through your through your finger
it's the same principle as that just a
little wavelength of light that goes
into the brain and from that we can
infer what's going on in the brain so
this light goes through the skull it
goes through the skull and let me just
die vert here and just tell you one
principle until in order to understand
this you need to eat them you only need
to understand one thing about how the
brain works and that is that when active
neuro tissue is involved like say your
visual system is working it's active
neural tissue when that happens your
brain is recruiting blood to that
locally active area and that blood is
highly oxygenated as it turns out that
change in oxygenation is the signal that
we use in fMRI which is the traditional
imaging technology it is also it is also
the basis for the signal that we use in
near-infrared spectroscopy so we shine a
little light into the brain it goes all
the way through the skull it goes down
about three centimeters and then it
bounces back up and when it bounces back
up part of it has been absorbed but what
has been absorbed depends on whether it
has gone through highly oxygenated blood
or whether it has gone through blood
that is deoxygenated or parts of the
brain that are not working so so sorry
go ahead
so you're looking at brains while people
are - brains while people are talking to
each other that's exactly right so now
we're free from the scanner and we can
actually put people in front of each
other and put these little lasers like
those swim caps on their heads and have
them talking interrelating looking at
each other and we have a whole new
neuroscience in front of us and this is
the neuroscience that aims to understand
activity of the human brain when we're
actually interacting in real time in
natural situations were behaving in ways
that connect us not just ourselves but
connect us to other people so what you
find goes on in the brains of people who
are talking to each other well partially
that the the tradition the traditional
work in neuroscience has taught us a
great deal Oh has taught us a great deal
about what we know about how the
language system actually works we know
we've got tools for Anna Keyes area for
reception got tools for production and
these guys
kind of work back and forth in a single
brain well as it turns out just as you
might expect they work back and forth
when you're talking to each other and so
we can see two brains
when using Wernicke's area and Broca's
area in ways that are taking turns with
each other as we're communicating
there's a picture of wernicki is word
comprehension and broke his brain is
speech production that's so in
conversation they wouldn't actually come
alive they do they work back and forth
me to them now that isn't too surprising
you would expect that is so and so we've
used these these first level of
experiments to just to document our
methodologies you know if you know an
answer to something as a scientist it's
a really nice thing to find it
particularly when you're starting
something new and so we've used these
talking back and forth experiments to
document what we know about the brain
already and and what do these
measurements these wavelets actually
show do they line up or yes what what
happens I think there's some other
slides there that show what happens when
two brains are actually in in a dialogue
with each other you have to remember
that the our two brains are a little bit
like cell phones because what we're
doing is sending and receiving wireless
communications so we're talking to each
other we're looking at each other so you
can think of two people as kind of us
kind of cellphones and you think what is
what are those signals that are going
back and forth across people well
there's the sound signals through the
visual signals and so on and you watch
the machinery of the two brains actually
receiving and sending and receiving and
sending just very much like the original
oh yeah that's an interesting that's an
interesting picture sending and
receiving like you would expect a model
cellphone to do what we learn from these
techniques and I think that was the
question that you asked is that in the
case of dialogue when people are
looking at each other that parts of our
brains are in synchrony with our partner
so if I'm talking to you my production
area Broca's area is resonating with
your Verna Keyes area your reception
area and when you're talking to me it
alternates and so our brains in some
sense fuse they fuse as we become a unit
by talking by sending and receiving and
sending and receiving so forgive me for
asking a little bit ahead here but that
means ourselves each of these two cells
become somewhat overlapping if our self
is involved with what our brain is our
brain changes when we're talking I
believe that that's the new idea that
comes from this new opportunity in
neuroscience to study two brains
together because what we see is that
partners become a unit they become a
unit in our brains tend to work in a
partnership sharing node are we looking
at a picture of world peace I I wish it
were so simple but I do think that as we
begin to understand the neural machinery
that is involved in interpersonal
interrelationships that we can begin to
understand better the biological nature
of conflict perhaps this resolution
between humans now I noticed you had
face recognition up there also something
that goes back and forth yeah I'm
thinking about how we can now talk to
Siri and say I'd like to talk
face-to-face with a friend of mine who's
on the other side of the planet we are
now living increasingly in something
called web world so to speak where we
can in present time communicate
throughout the entire species the human
species I'm leaping ahead here but if
you all are beginning to show us on
graphs that our minds getting to sync
with each other when we talk that might
give us hope that we could explain this
to each other that it matters what we
say to each other and you're showing us
how we change we get angry or get out of
sync well that's the hope I think we
have to understand that these are very
early days with this this new technology
turns out that technology has been
around for quite a while but it hasn't
been used in this application so we're
just beginning as scientists to
understand how to use this new tool it's
a little bit like 15 years ago or so
when functional MRI was relatively new
we didn't quite know how to use it and
so it is the hope that we can open some
many new doors in neuroscience to
directly answer some of these questions
how do we how do our brains work
differently when we're working together
whether we're face to face or whether
we're on some media on the other side of
the planet or how does television
effectors are out when we identify with
the movie star or or when advertising
affects us or this is a family show so
get Masters and Johnson involved here
yet I suppose but more intimate I mean
or between people I mean the mind it's
blowing my mind so to speak the the idea
you could eventually have these two
people connected who are on different
sides of the planet talking to each
other on the cell phone on skype it's
really interesting I had a summer
student last summer who wanted to know
how brains differed when they were
talking face-to-face and whether they
went they were texting each other and I
started this with the notion that Oh
texting really didn't involve much of
the social brain and what we're going to
see is this active social areas of the
brain when were face-to-face but we're
not going to see very much in texting
well I was plenty wrong as often times
students show the professors are wrong
and this was one of them that the
texting actually involved a lot more
what we call the temporal parietal
Junction that's a sweet spot in the
brain that we think is sensitive to
social interactions so it turns out that
in all the people that were texting each
other they were involving this very
special part of the brain and we
interpreted this as a greater
involvement of theory of mind ways of
projecting yourself into another person
but anyway so the moral is we don't
really know very much about what goes on
in the brain and social interactions and
we have an awful lot to learn but you've
opened the door here we've opened the
door yeah and and that's what's really
exciting it's very humbling as a
scientist it's very humbling to start at
the very beginning of kind of a new area
but it's your hypothesis was basically
proved there would be something they
looked at that's right
dr. fara um how does this change your
understanding of consciousness why was I
surprised I always do that when somebody
says the word consciousness let me
answer a similar question not exactly
that if I may which is you know how does
how does it change the way I think about
you know sort of how people think about
people how people think about the
message that they're trying to convey to
somebody else and whether or not that
somebody else has received it those
kinds of issues which I'm sure
consciousness plays a role in there but
it it is I think we can figure out a lot
about the kinds of things that joy is
studying and the kinds of things that
make us human right
you know we a simple conversation
actually involves all kinds of
processing of not only what's on your
mind but what you think the listener
already knows needs to hear to have what
you're saying to her be clear so that
back and forth is
I mean yes it involves the sort of nuts
and bolts of the language system
Wernicke's area Broca's area auditory
etc but as as joy was just mentioning
towards the end so much more all these
social areas our brain has a ton of
hardware you know neural wetware that's
dedicated to just representing people
cells our own selves other cells the
temporoparietal junction that she
mentioned is specialized for thinking
about what is on somebody else's mind
and what they're trying to do and where
they're going etc etc my TPJ is just
noticing that little finger raised which
tells me Bill wants to ask follow-up
change the direction that's my teeth
each a so it's it's communication
language per se what is that acronym
again TPJ temporoparietal junction and
that's pretty pretty good Anatomy yeah
you know the the temporal lobes are the
kind of long sausage II things on the
side so to go back for a moment to the
slippery concept of consciousness made
you sit up I've heard some people say
that consciousness is basically
awareness whatever using words to try to
get it into this concept here but dr.
Prince what's the difference between
awareness and attention for example well
I I think they're actually the same I
mean one of the things that we've been
able to do with the signs of
consciousness is start to relate this
very ethereal concept consciousness
awareness experience to things that we
understand much better how does
consciousness relate to memory how does
it relate to attention those are
questions that we can ask scientifically
and if even if we never get a full
handle and how a physical thing like the
brain can give rise to experience we can
understand what processes in the brain
are taking place when we are conscious
and doing that we can learn a lot of
things about consciousness that
very important so suppose we're using
Joyce knew technology on somebody who's
watching a magic show and there's this
sleight of hand so a very good magician
might you know pull pull a card out of
thin air and how do they do this well of
course the card was somewhere and if
they have a camera trained on the sleeve
or wherever it was located it would be
very easy to consciously experience its
original location but a good magician is
going to distract a good magician might
use hand gestures or even voice to get
the viewer to miss out on on the trick I
think conversation is like that in
general when we're having a conversation
we're directing each other's attention
and there are many things we might be
attending to we might be attending to
the emotional expression of our
conversation partner we might be
attending to to ourselves how do we
sound how are we self presenting we
might be attending to social hierarchy
is this somebody who has a higher status
its neuroscientist psychologist studying
conversation very rarely study attention
they very rarely study power they very
rarely study social dynamics they rarely
study things like compassion or
aggression or impatience so conversation
isn't just a string of words it's a it's
a kind of flow of multiple channels of
information that are directing what
people notice and what they tend to the
conscious experience you have what you
notice the content you take away is not
just enumerated in the words that are
presented to you but in all of these
other cues that are telling you what the
meaning is so and consciousness is so
attention is I think something that
allows information to flow in the
nervous system when you're having a
perceptual encounter with the world a
lot of what gets in gets in subliminally
we're totally unaware of it you can
measure this you can show that if you
present something very quickly say for
17 milliseconds followed by a mask
people have no capacity to experience it
whatsoever
I'm fascinating as a journalist I
noticed I asked you so consciousness is
and you very suddenly said and so
attention is it
as tension is the difference between
something getting stuck in your
perceptual systems and sort of hanging
out there indefinitely and passing
forward to other parts of the nervous
system where you can think about it use
it reasoning use it in deliberation
consciousness is attention and attention
is this doorway that opens that allows
perception to access the rest already
getting the trope this is attention this
all sounds very logical disagree please
I mean so I would say attention is may
be necessary for consciousness but you
know I I don't get the heebie-jeebies
when people talk about attention that's
a good mainstream cognitive neuroscience
concept the but consciousness often
means in these kinds of discussions that
subjective sense of what something feels
like how do we know I know that I'm
paying attention is there a subject you
user is objective so you know Ned Locke
a colleague of yours yes at NYU
philosophy um distinguishes between
consciousness sub a for access or you
could say attention to that is
consciousness in the sense that we can
access some information we can access
that somebody looks surprised but what
we've just said or you know whatever and
consciousness sub T for phenomenal or
phenomenology right that kind of feeling
of what it's like to be experiencing
that and I think whenever we're talking
about subjective mental states
phenomenological mental states I think
that's that's when I do jump when people
hit me with consciousness you know what
I'm not expecting it and it's some it's
spooky
it is spooky I think we are profoundly
ignorant and it will be about how you
get that subjectivity out of thinking
about this from before I felt a great
relief when I heard there was a
philosopher named Thomas
solved the problem he said consciousness
is simply one of the irreducible 'z of
the universe is just there like gravity
and mass and various creatures tap into
it and reconstruct it in various ways
this to me is the fuse and Tom Nagel was
a teacher of mine he brought me to this
subject that I'm very much in his debt
Ned is a colleague Ned Walken we've
talked together and work together on
various things I think there's a way in
which we get ourselves into this air of
mystery
that's needless and it creates problems
that aren't really they are when people
used to talk about life they were
absolutely mystified how life could
figure in a physical world and when
things like the structure of DNA were
discovered it was a major intellectual
breakthrough because suddenly this thing
that seemed absolutely mystified
absolutely impossible to explain was
understood in physical terms Descartes
thought the big mystery of the mind was
not conscious experience but reason they
cart maybe one of the greatest minds in
the history of Western thought could not
figure out how reason could be
physically explained then computers came
along and we have a program that in a
very simple way is doing complex
derivations of mathematical proofs
that's reasoning so I think we're going
to get to a point with consciousness
where once we found out what are the
psychological processes in the
neurobiological processes that take
place that make the difference between
seeing something and not then we're
going to be in a position to say that
some of this sort of wallowing in
mystery was really unnecessary and other
very exciting questions can be answered
well I noticed you're nodding and so
maybe you get your half to agreeing with
him maybe but let me ask you will come
back so definitely I just think I wanted
to back Martha it's not just that it's
difficult to define and maybe loosen
maybe not since I'm backing both of you
up and I think one of the important
discoveries from psychology and
neuroscience over the past decade or two
is not just that it's hard to define
semantically and phenomenology from
neurologically but that actually it's
not as required or central as we
thought it is whether you find it as
awareness or even attention or
consciousness what's not is required
consciousness that a lot of things we
thought required conscious awareness
actually don't and my perspective on
that comes from research on memory well
I was gonna ask you to get back to our
title neurons and self how does memory
define the self and what your you were
just about to go there I guess what I
was going to say is that you know if we
think about memory in many ways in the
most kind of mundane ways so if I ask
everyone here they remember where they
were when they bought their tickets to
this show or receive their tickets to
this show okay we can actually now
you're thinking about it you can bring
back that memory and that in of itself
is an interesting process that we can
understand in their neurobiological
terms so you brought it to conscious
awareness because I asked you to but
that's really just one way in which we
remember that results in some kind of
conscious awareness or attention but we
know that those kind of memories
influence our behaviors all the time
without having brought them to mind in
any consciously explained way so it's
something that we used to think that
consciousness is an incredibly central
feature of memory retrieval and we now
know that those same neurons that allow
you to create and retrieve memories are
actually also supporting a whole host of
behaviors that are not consciously aware
that are related to memory but we have
to kind of redefine what we mean by what
a memory is you mean it's doing a lot of
thinking without us asking our
permission and without us being in
charge yes I think that's good news in
the bad news so so how do memories
contribute to the sense of self how do
they get connected it's a it's it's a
great question all right I mean many
ways what we're trying to understand is
if I ask every person in this room in
one week what they remember from this
event tonight most of us will remember
very little that we know for sure but
probably what we do remember will be
very different my memory of tonight will
be different from your memory of tonight
will be different from their memory of
tonight individually and I think that's
sort of interest
because the the reason for that
difference has to do with our
expectations our interests our
motivations so I think things that I
would think of as a kind of representing
ourselves so who we are
is a filter on what we meant what we
remember the memories we create but that
filter doesn't come out of nowhere I'd
say it itself is built on memories from
what happened before and it's this
ability to link memories over a lifetime
in that kind of endless dialogue between
what we expect what happens what gets
remembers and how that shapes our
memories one of my favorite quotes on
this topic is from Marcel Proust
who said remembrance of things past was
not necessarily remembrance of things as
they occurred right so the idea is that
we have biases in our memory we change
what we remember in subtle and
idiosyncratic personal ways that relate
to our our selves and episodic memory
episodic memory is a jargon professional
term and memory research to describe
your memory for an episode like when you
bought your tickets or when I was asked
to participate in this so it's memory
for an event in time and what the
picture on the screen is showing you are
the parts of the brain as identified and
healthy human beings with functional
magnetic resonance imaging which joi
mentioned those are the parts of the
brain that shows significant activity
associated with the creation and
retrieval of these sorts of memories
creation and retrieval I mean I've heard
it said that memory is not like a tape
recorder it's it's not just feeding back
over and over every time you remember
something you're reconstructing it exact
and never the same twice well okay it
doesn't have to not be the same twice it
can be but it does but it isn't
necessarily the same and this is where
these biases I think play out and I
think this is where we start to get to a
connection between memory and self in a
more obvious way which is when if I did
that you know I now did a test on every
one and said remember that when you
bought the tickets by doing that you're
bringing up a memory and you're bringing
it up in this context and your brain is
now linking those two memories together
because it's retrieving a memory in a
new context and kind of recreating the
memory rewriting the memory you're
beginning to be able to show some of
this with neuroscience and looking in
the brains you can see this happening to
some extent yes right so we are we work
in a lab and these are difficult
questions and so we take these
interesting questions like what it means
to have a self and connect memories
across a lifetime but we don't put you
in a standard for your lifetime what we
do is we create computer games that
stimulate this kind of process over the
span of an hour or two or a few days
where we have common elements come up
and we can ask when common elements come
up in experience as you see on the
screen can we track the retrieval of the
memory and then it's it's connection
with this new situation that just came
up and so we can kind of track how in
that sense how two memories get
networked together or get linked and
what that means for how we use memories
later on and how do how do memories
affect our sense of the future the one
that I think the really interesting
discoveries in memory in recent years is
you know we think coming back to that
example instead of thinking of memory as
like just memory for one event in time
in one moment it turns out that the same
neurons the same brain tissue the same
regions of the brain that we know are
absolutely essential for creating these
kind of episodic memories have a much
broader role in behavior they're
essential for planning and what we call
prospecting though imagining events in
the future and that's I think a really
good hint to the importance of memory
and how essential memory is not just for
a sort of reminiscing about the past but
for planning it in a way it's a more
mundane role but I think a much more
central one in imagining what will
happen when this program is over what's
gonna happen tomorrow what decisions
should I make about my retirement that
we use memory and leverage it to make
predictions about the future right
really and this slide we have data
connectivity between the hippocampus in
the striatum
let me so let me define some of that and
it gets at this point so the part of the
brain that is probably most central for
creating these kind of episodic memories
that we saw in part on the earlier slide
is called the hippocampus there are
fascinating stories that sort of the
history of science of how we discovered
that the hippocampus is important for
memory I think is is is really
interesting goes back to a famous
patient HM we can maybe come back to
that explain this so the hippocampus is
important for those kind of memories the
stratum is a separate part of the brain
that for a very long time we thought was
important for completely different sorts
of behavior the stratum is the part of
the brain that's disrupted most
significantly in Parkinson's disease for
example and it's in charge of kind of
planned actions motivated actions so
many of us have shown that there's
important crosstalk correlation
connectivity between the hippocampus
pretty retrieving memories and the
stratum planning actions and suggests
that there is a way in which memories
are feeding into many of our behaviors
even when we're not consciously aware of
that
after all the past doesn't exist in a
sense except in the present tense
instant of our mind it's gone you look
for it's not there you go down to
Gettysburg and all your findings
McDonald's and we often play it over as
if it was or our own life right right
right no I think that's exactly right
it's a quote another very wise man
Daniel Kahneman the economists once said
you know we make we make decisions not
based on our experiences what we think
we're doing but we make decisions based
on our memory of those experiences
so again memories sort of this important
filter you're now able to show this in
some of the workings of this dynamic in
the brain what connects what doesn't
connect right and what what this image
that you're viewing now shows you is
kind of another angle on this story and
another reason why we believe it's very
useful and important beyond the
philosophy - nothing wrong
but that understanding these brain
regions even though many of us really
just want to understand just want to
understand how you know the mind works
but that by understanding the
differences between the behaviors that
these different parts of the brain
support we hope we can use that to
understand disease better and this is
showing for example that the hippocampus
and the stratum differ not just in and
where they are and you can see there the
hippocampus is teal and the stratum is
in purple so they differ in their
support of episodes and inferences for
the hippocampus and habits and kind of
actions for the stratum but that they
also are by virtue of being different
structures play roles in different kinds
of disease so that is very helpful for
us for using what we hope are become
behavioral tests of cognition and
reasoning and B and behavior to probe
the roles of these joy at this point
what Daffin has just said do you think
it's going to help us narrow in zero in
on what self might be if it does exist
the concept of self that we're trying to
zero in on well certainly - back - no
yes I mean that the notion that we are
that we are what we remember we are what
our experiences but what our experiences
contribute to our sense of well-being
certainly yes and I'm always thinking
about this now in sort of my new lens of
how these these ideas of self and who we
are are communicated to another person
and one of the new ideas that builds on
this is that we as individuals in the
communication with another actually
engage in a very active process of
sharing some of the recent experiments
that we have done is having people just
look at each other you ever wonder what
happens when you just look at someone
somebody else that
wonderful glance have you ever heard of
love at first sight it actually is
probably true that there is so much that
goes on in a look that we share with
another person about ourselves it's a
very very poignant aspect face to face
face to face I've heard some scientists
say that one of the things that
distinguishes our species is that we
have by evolved by far the most
expressive face of any species is that
that's part of what you're talking about
part that is exactly what I'm talking
about I don't know how if we have the
most expressive face on the planet but
it's a very expressive one and what that
tells us is that our brains are very
much designed to capture those
expressions and we tell other people
about ourselves through our facial
expressions and so one of the things
that we're seeing with this new study is
how active we how active perceptions are
so that as we look at somebody else as
we talk with other people we share who
we are but we also actively interrogate
the person that we're talking to and you
can see them you know you see in your
experiments how the brain does this yes
yes that's that's that's the goal and we
do see new levels of specificity for
engagement of that kind fascinate get to
the philosophy a quick question for
Martha what you've heard so far been
watching you nodding and being fast so
why and and this conversation you think
add to the potential for understanding
what self might be I I do maybe that's
why I'm nodding so much I also not to
kind of just say I hear you I hear you I
disagree with you about hear you
[Laughter]
but but yeah I mean you know this
actually I'm gonna defer to the
philosopher here about this but my sense
is in philosophy when people trot when
philosophers try to define what makes a
person the same person over all kinds of
changes from you know relaxed because
they're just back from vacation to you
know madly finishing a grant proposal to
you know you at age five you at age 85
that the the best account seems to have
something to do with this chaining of
memories this kind of fabric of memories
and that has really interesting and sad
implications for diseases that impair
the formation infantile of memory like
Alzheimer's and I don't know if you
exactly that's what all of this just
made me think of we we have an opposite
case we talked about thinking that
people who have dementia or Alzheimer's
lose their sense of self apparently and
you're all nodding that that's what
seems to happen is when memories go self
goes or large parts of it or something
like that
now here from the empirical philosopher
there's no field it's a perfect Segway
because it's exactly why we need
empirical philosophy John Locke who was
mentioned in the introductory film wrote
a book in 1690 that became the textbook
for the mind for the next 200 years
called NASA concerning human
understanding called an essay concerning
human understanding human understanding
in that book he advances a theory of
what a self is and what makes somebody
the same self over time and his answer
as it's most usually interpreted is
memory memory is what links us to our
past so as good students of philosophy
my collaborators and I assumed something
like this was right and we wondered is
this
really how ordinary people think about
identity and we started to test it we
started to test it in various ways but
typically using questionnaires we asked
people about a bunch of traits about a
bunch of traits your memories your
cognitive capacities your personality
your vocations in life your occupation
where you live and you're not using the
word identity as synonymous with self we
our interest is in the question what
makes somebody the same self what
changes take place all of us are
changing all the time
human beings are radically dynamic we
are the most capable of learning of any
creature we know and that means we're
constantly just sitting here every time
you hear a sentence your brain has been
rewired something is getting stored a
new trace is there but you feel like
you're the same person so part of
understanding what the self is it's
understanding what remains constant such
that you can say I'm still me this
morning I'm still the same person I was
this morning even though I've been
learning all day so we wanted to know
what what matters there and we want to
know what our ordinary intuitions about
this so we ask suppose you lose all of
your memories or consider a relative who
is in advanced age and losing memories
through through neural degeneration are
they the same person and for a question
like that the answer was usually well
they've changed a little bit but they're
pretty much the same and we asked about
other capacities what if their
personality changes what if their
interests change pretty much the same
the one thing that really seemed to have
the most dramatic impact on identity
according to our ordinary judgments is
morality values if your values change or
if you imagine a relative who suddenly
who spent a life dedicated to left
causes to voting for Democrats who
suddenly become a right-wing Republican
right that's our that's our response
okay this is a very current subject
yes
how long before we could avoid
mentioning it but but first not to take
it for granted I want to take the Father
Brown approach to solving things I want
to not use any terms presuming that we
know what they are you're just talking
about morality and values synonymously
what is a value what just give us a any
definition I think a value is some some
kind of preference for how people should
be or behave if the preference related
your social aspect suppose it's better
to be like this than that that's right
and morality is in judgment of good and
bad this is a better way to be this is a
worse way to be and morality is roughly
the same morality I mean that some of
our values are good and bad about other
demands like good and bad art are good
and bad food but morality is about about
the social domain and the values that we
have and morality are very related to to
reward and Punishment so when somebody
transgress when they violate our
preferences for good and bad we think
they deserve to be punished in some way
so morality is is really about
regulating social behavior in a way that
can chords with accords with our
preference all right so you're talking
about identity political so we've
measured in a lot of ways if you look at
political values they're very often
moral because policy is directing
behavior but religion too is very
important for morality people have all
kinds of values just about what counts
as a good human life how should how
should we live somebody who is not
ambitious not pursuing goals not trying
to add something to the universe might
be frowned upon as as as lazy as a
failed human being so we have a lot of
that anything that involves some belief
about how to live well we're getting
into areas that we've got to get into
they're large where the large religion
of course causes is believed to cause a
lot of disagreement but there's also
been a lot of studies or what they all
have in common for example I've seen
studies that show that all the major
religions have some version of the
Golden Rule
basic compassion don't kill don't kill
yourself don't be killed can be found in
some version of another and all the
major religions at least in the non
extreme versions of them so there are
certainly overlaps but I think it's very
important
to see difference because one of the
things we do in constructing yourself
but somebody says who are you if we all
were the same if our values were all the
same that wouldn't be a question worth
asking so somebody who asked about your
identity is asking which of these slots
do fall into which are your values what
are the things that you really care
about and most importantly behind that
question you're trying to find out is
this somebody who's like me or somebody
who's different is this somebody with
whom I can collaborate cooperate former
friendship former romance or is it
somebody who's so morally different from
me that I can't imagine relating to them
when you discover that a person you've
just been having a long conversation
with is voting for the other party how
many of you who are say Bernie
supporters discovered that a close
friend supports Hillary and had this
drawing moment where you really wonder
can I be friends with this person
anymore
we won't even mention the other New
Yorker on the ticket so I mean there is
there is a way in which our selves are
not just these individual things they're
all about forming these social
connections I have to ask you this point
as an empirical philosopher do you test
these things using brain images or using
some other kinds of empirical data we
mostly use other kinds of empirical data
so we're asking people questions we're
looking at right now we're looking at
parole decision so why do you let
somebody off from a prison sentence
maybe it's because their behavior
exchange maybe it's because a lot of
time is passed and you think they've
suffered enough already in prison but
maybe it's because you think their
values have changed and they're no
longer the same person you've actually
kept somebody in prison who didn't
commit the crime so your idea about
who's their self really is just suddenly
changed when you heard about who they're
gonna what they did or what they didn't
do or that they in other words judges
are making decisions about what the self
the other self is that's right or a
conversation about who to vote for
suddenly you switch the other self is
evil well that there is a lot of that
kind of judgment so one of the reasons
why we worry so much about moral change
is is there is this anxiety that
somebody who we cared about we felt
close to who you trusted is now on the
other side so forgive me for asking this
but it sounds to me like you're
describing a basic dynamic of a human
history and it's horrendous cycle of war
and I more war III think one of the one
of the really important discoveries at
social psychology it wasn't the
discovery we know
through human history but one of things
that we've been able to measure is how
people form groups and there's old
results dating back decades of what's
called the minimal group effects so you
can just arbitrarily assign people to
any group they form strong allegiance
with anyone who's in the same group and
hostility towards others morality is the
ultimate of group membership and these
findings are are universal for the human
species wherever we are on the planet I
you know as somebody who really is
interested in culture I'm really
interested in how human minds are shaped
by experience values are created through
history created through the cauldron of
culture did that extend I'm reluctant to
speak too much and universals I would
like to hope that we can find ways of
getting along and forming affiliations
with people whose values differ
dramatically from ours but it certainly
has been the case that this fault line
has led to a tremendous amount of
conflict and violence in human history
right Mars I see you nodding again with
somebody to suggest you might disagree
with no no that's a how interesting not
so so well we stand the subject of self
you've done you have an experiment of
some kind that you've you've done or
some study with regard to political
identity well we've done a lot of
studies showing that what people
consider most important for our identity
is their moral values including their
their political values and then it
occurred to us that this really serves a
function and the function is forming
social alliances so it's not only
important to you that you vote a certain
way it's important that others know this
about you so how do we signal that how
do we make sure that everyone I meet
casually no matter how quickly has a
pretty good chance of guessing correctly
about what my moral values are so for
instance if you drive a pickup truck are
you more likely to be a Republican or a
Democrat if you drive a foreign car you
ask you me well I ask ask yourselves you
know if you drive a foreign car more
likely to be a Republican or a Democrat
if you say eat sushi more likely to be
able Republican or Democrat if you like
red meat if you read military history if
you like NASCAR racing and the what do
these things have to do with morality
NASCAR racing but we can guess that a
NASCAR enthusiast is more likely to be
conserved
liberal why and the reason is all of
these aspects of human taste are
signally they're trying to communicate
to others what social group we belong so
you're saying that one's enthusiasms or
groups you join have a big element in
them of which group do I want to
identify with in signal thereby to
others for a warm fuzzy group feeling
antagonistic feeling you have so I
believe some pictures to give us a job
so we got interested can you tell by
looking whether somebody is a Democrat
or a Republican so we collected dozens
and dozens of faces we'd use an
arbitrary method of generating a big
picture set of faces and we don't even
know the political party that these
people belong to so it's all it's all
just whether people have an opinion
about it and we found overwhelmingly
that that people do so so we can take a
look at some examples and should we
bring up the house lights yeah let's
let's have a let's have a look so now
what you're going to do now is you're
gonna vote you're gonna vote so this
person isn't wearing any political
buttons or any any kind of paraphernalia
that we tell you how many of you think
this is a Republican raise your hands
how do you think this is a Democrat so
why you know that's really weird what
let's look at another example okay so
some cases maybe maybe harder let's see
how this one goes how many think this is
a Republican how many say Democrat okay
so still big big big majority next one
okay so what do we have here how many
say Republican in this case okay the
house goes up and Democrat anyone so
just I mean obviously we know we all
know counter examples we all know people
who spent their their put their lives on
the line for this country working for
military causes even though they vote
for the Democratic Party that's not
unheard of but the fact that we can
signal this in some way is an indication
that we fact we have such consensus on
these opinions chose how important this
is in social decision-making let's look
at another case okay how many say
Republican
how many say Democrat Wow
so overwhelming and it's just that she's
wearing black right we're trying now to
figure out what drives these decisions
let's look at one more example and
you'll get a kind of complete for this
okay how many say Republican here ok so
here we got the majority anyone to say
Democrat here love you and I think
there's one more okay so how many say
Republican how many say Democrat so very
very for those of you who've not been
able to see the hands go up
we're probably if we measure this when
we'd probably be in the 90s percentile
in terms of agreement on which one was a
Republican which one is a Democrat
sometimes its ethnicity sometimes its
occupation like the military commitment
but what about the beard what about the
black hat the fact that randomly chosen
people on the street are conveying to
others what party they belong to I think
is one of the most revealing things I've
encountered in my investigations about
the self how many think I'm a Republican
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this raises a lot of questions to me why
are you applauding what are you
applauding for why were you so amused
that you laughed at each one of those
questions I mean this is a very serious
question what was so amusing about this
and I've got other questions such as if
you showed these pictures to somebody in
a different time in a different century
very important even if they didn't have
they might have looked conservative or
some people whatever that means that so
in other words you're also showing us
that this empirical data is building up
some of the understandings of some of
the ugly sides of human nature or parts
of it such as stereotypes and judgmental
I mean this is talking about the basis
of our judgment that's my stratum right
I have to reprogram my straight also
definitely you word approving I'll say
that I thought the most interesting
there's what's one of the interesting
things if I may this is I'm outside of
my neuroscience area of expertise here
was that I think people were laughing
because we all recognize it's silly to
reach these conclusions at least in part
but I actually think that Jesse's last
comment was the most interesting one the
point is not that we have strong
opinions about this we know that people
use stereotypes and all kinds of ways I
think the point is that all of us use
take advantage of those cues in our
choices every day so it's a social
projection of that which I thought was
actually directly related to a joy was
saying about how we communicate
non-verbally and verbally in that way
because we're soliciting our people like
us can know we're signalling to them so
you three brain scientists who actually
look at the gray matter and the purple
and green and dark matters and white
matters find something to talk about
with this philosopher that may be able
to match your scientific data from your
brain labs with the sign to the type of
data that he's turning up from these
could you explain the connection there
let me just add a little bit to that I
think
one of the things that fascinates me the
most about what you're talking about is
what it tells us about our brains and
how actively we interrogate and seek
information about others and how we
relate that to ourselves
it's as if in that seeking process we
become unified in some way with with the
other and I think that the next stage in
neuroscience is going to tell us a lot
more about those very fundamental
mechanisms and one of my goals in
neuroscience is to move this most
fascinating idea from the hands of
philosophers well maybe maybe empirical
philosophers are different and but put
it in the hands of neuroscience so that
we can understand the neural machinery
in the neural mechanisms that drive this
connection that we have with other
people and how it is we interrogate
other people to understand who they are
just if I can if I can quickly come to
the defense of well I I mean I really
look forward to that day and I think
this stuff you're doing with really the
kinds of methods that can study social
interaction the brain imaging are
extremely exciting one of the problems
that I've had with neuroscience has a
field given its current technologies is
it really misses out on the social we
have in this culture Biophilia we think
that if something is biologically
explained it's real and if it's cultural
or about ideas or even about the social
it's somehow less real so we have the
for instance if you look at the National
Institute of Health find the studies on
addiction like alcoholism overwhelmingly
that money goes to studies looking at
genes and brain circuits right it's
looking at those factors but we know
that socio genic factors factors about
where you live factors about poverty
with which martha studies all of those
things are at least maybe more important
studies of genetic relatedness show that
if you're an alcoholic
there is about a 15% chance that your
offspring will be alcoholics that means
the overwhelming majority of them are
not those studies if they're done with
adoption the effects are tiny
often go away are very very inconsistent
across studies if they're done cross
culturally the numbers begin to look
ridiculous so America has about a 5%
alcoholism Ray Russia is about 16% is
Lama countries are mostly under 1% so we
can have a 16 times increase in whether
you become an alcoholic if you're born
in Russia as opposed to in Iran and
you're looking forward to determine the
neurological brain sinus can can connect
why these things happen that's the
future I'm excited about bringing
culture into the brain showing how the
circuits of the brain are playing a role
in taking that cultural information and
driving behavior
this is not what the neuroscientist or
one of them is supposed to say but I'll
say it anyway which is yes I would like
very much for us to understand this at a
neural level and many of us would but I
think maybe I'd kind of back up Jessi's
point and say it even more strongly
which is there are many societal
questions about behavior that we know
that that behavior emerges from the
brain because it's not coming from
anywhere else but when understanding the
brain doesn't necessarily help us treat
that behavior and there's a lot of other
information that's necessary and so I'd
argue that for things like understanding
is there a self what is it self what
does this have to do with how we
socialize and any questions at that
level that complex questions about what
it means to be human we're never gonna
understand them only in terms of neurons
maybe not never maybe one day but when
that day gets closer it will be the
psychologists and the philosophers who
have set us up to start thinking about
those questions in intelligent ways just
saying that something happens in the
brain the end of itself doesn't tell us
how it is it's neutral it doesn't have
morality connected to it and also the
more you guys have talked about learning
about the brain the more I think
potential dangers of hacking into the
brain of misusing this information the
old human problem learning things that I
mean you could learn how to control
minds or they could do DNA so Martha's
done some
but thought in depth about these issues
of sort of at the ethics of neuroscience
yeah
well how do you how do you apply them
you know to understand a system to
thoroughly understand a system is to be
able to control it right to predict it
and even potentially to control it and
you know you can you can rest easy
tonight knowing that we neuroscientists
are still pretty clueless about how this
incredibly complex system works you know
but but we are learning something I mean
I think the things that you've heard
from from joy and Daphna you know show
that neuroscience is beginning to get a
handle on some of these things you know
there's a lot of ways to manipulate
brain function drugs is sort of the
time-honored way you sort of tweak you
know the neuro chemistry but people are
now using brain stimulation to do that
even non-invasive brain stimulation
which sounds almost like an oxymoron
right like how can you stimulate the
brain but not open up the body except
that you can do that with electrical
fields and magnetic fields and there's a
lot of research now and a lot of actual
just people doing it you can go online
and buy devices that will electrically
stimulate your brain from outside of
your head and so that's you know now
that's people doing it for themselves
but you could imagine going back to your
judges sentencing people you know you
could imagine a sort of well-meaning
policy of saying we're not gonna just
lock you up we're gonna actually try to
rehabilitate you you just need to sort
of you know
regulate your you know look dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex and so we're
gonna just you know indeed is sometimes
it's good people buy full spec
like to look at in the morning to beat
the winter depression that that there's
all kinds of good benefits here but yes
it could be abused yeah I mean you have
to answer like who has the right to you
know whose brain is it anyway kind of
like who has the right to mm-hmm and now
we're gonna get back to self here but
this is already reminding me of this is
a beautiful peaceful conversation about
something that's not always so peaceful
I gather in the academic world it is
it's called what is it
neuro scepticism I've shown the books of
some neuroscientists to some
psychologists were very thoughtful
people who say well this person knows
enough about the brain to be dangerous
and maybe someday but these neurologists
think they can control things and they
can't you all are nodding you're aware
that this these fights are going on
right I think the term is called neuro
bollocks
neuro bollocks Merril bollocks it's a
very popular term that recent that that
is in a way a way of trashing
neuroscience and the notion that we can
learn about ourselves well I could see
how psychiatrists and shrinks should be
threatened by you guys because they've
they figured out they have to just talk
to a patient about some event in the
past and get them to just talk and they
fear that you all are going to come in
and say no no but I'm not representing I
don't think it's fair to reduce it to
insecurity or threat I think there's
some times as a society we get so
carried away and how exciting this all
is and its potential down the road that
there's a feeling that we're already
there when in truth it's a very young
field understanding complex
psychological mental phenomena is really
in its early stages right that's where
we started by saying not long ago we
thought some of this was in the heart so
we know it's in the brain and we know
we're in the brain between that and
understanding the how of how these
things happen there's a long way and I
think a lot of the neuro skepticism both
outside but also within the field is
really a healthy sign of a growing field
it's sort of like in its adolescence
maybe rather than its infancy where
there's a lot of rebellion which I think
it's healthy for advancing the science
right you're reminding me of an ancient
was it the Egyptians or I forget who
used to think the thought and reason
happened not here but in the liver and
that the soul was based in the liver
they hadn't quite figured it out yet you
all have got a different idea about it
but perhaps you're connecting some of
these things up because the conversation
we're having in the green room about
next year was about how actually it's
all the little microbes inside of us
that are really controlling us and using
us just to walk them around so we have
to study the minds and the brains of the
neuro of the microbes but that's that's
next year bill can I just want to come
on the on the point that the anxiety
about neuroscience is connected to brain
control I think we also need to remember
that behavior is more typically and
quite powerfully controlled by social
forces so mmm you know many of my family
members were killed in the Holocaust
have they been of a different Creed they
would have been the perpetrators not the
victims and I think we all need to
remember so you all guessed my political
orientation maybe not correctly maybe
correctly I won't say but I will say I
was born and raised in New York City and
I have I been born and raised upstate or
in the Midwest or in the south where
I've also lived I might vote for the
other party and so it's very important
to remember that human behavior is
dramatically affected by things without
direct biological intervention right now
we're so far away technologically from
changing behavior by altering brain
circuits that we should be much more
worried about the social forces than the
by lot and you raise of great hope here
which is that if general acceptance
among the world's scientists and
philosophers and economists and
psychologists of some of these basic
patterns that are true of all humans
then when we see horrendous behavior
that could lead to great damage such as
storm troopers marching in perfect
unison we could possibly on the new web
world this new global brain of global
mind if we can talk about it in those
terms spread the knowledge that look
folks this is a known disease let's all
get together and be open about it and
stop it before it happens that's very
optimistic but why not right that's
that's not impossible a reasonable hope
I think though began the by Ophelia's
that work here because when we start to
think about the bad things in the world
is a disease on the model of some sort
of biological and
we focus on interventions that are at
that level but most of the take violence
there's a lot of work on criminal genes
or people born bad and maybe there is
some variation and tendency towards
aggressive behavior that has a base in
biology but the effect size of social
causes like poverty which Martha's
worked on and I want to say this is an
extraordinary panel because all of those
neuroscientists on this panel study
things like anorexia nervosa or poverty
that are social factors that show that
the brain is not fixed but is constantly
changing and adapt into the social
setting if we want to change things like
the violence that exists in the world we
need to not be thinking about the Cure
at the biological level but at the
biosocial interact and the scientists
and all of you seem to be telling us
more and more that the you keep
disturbing that the brain is much more
flexible than anybody imagined there was
a headline recently that said that
they've discovered that there's one
organ in the body that has a different
DNA in it in the same organ you have a
lot of different DNA in the cells the
brain so that your your DNA is not it is
not the DNA in every brain cell but in
other words there's all kinds of ways
evolution has taught our bodies
apparently to take advantage of as much
flexibility as possible to adapt to
what's needed so to get back to our
central promise to figure out what about
the self I'll and and what we think
about the self in consciousness we have
a quote from Thomas Huxley
who was a biologist who if I'm not
mistaken as the fellow who advertised
how interesting Darwin was how it is
that anything so remarkable as a state
of consciousness comes about by
irritating nervous tissue is just as
unaccountable as the appearance of the
genie when Aladdin rubbed his lamp you
three brain scientists think that still
pertains it still is unaccountable or
you're beginning to account for it well
I don't think I'm gonna shift the
studying lamps but in state of
consciousness I guess the question would
be for him what did he think he meant by
state of consciousness I mean I think
this gets us back again to this question
of subjectivity versus objectivity
which I know sounds like dialogue from
an old Woody Allen building Diane Keaton
says you know if if what he means by
state of consciousness is basically the
focus of your attention then I think
it's wrong what he's saying I think we
have certainly in sort of a broad sketch
of it's not a detailed account of the
way in which the the neural networks of
our brain can kind of sift and select
for certain subsets of the information
impinging on your senses focus on
certain memories that you've encoded in
the past that you become quote conscious
of in the sense of aware or attending to
but I think what he's probably talking
about is that okay
people usually at some point in your
childhood
you've puzzled over the following
question what if what I see when I look
at something that I call red is looks to
you like what I see is what I would call
green right does this I can you couldn't
see people kind of you know musing that
you know when were 10 years old and
we're all philosophers and you know so
that difference between the experience
of red and the experience of green which
you can never sort out just by talking
to somebody right because I say well
does it look red to you and you say of
course it looks red because all your
life you've called that to me green
color right okay it's it's that
difference between the experience of red
and green okay that completely
subjective
experience that I don't think we have a
clue how that results from material went
for the first I think most people
thought of this problem but for the
first time I'm beginning to realize that
you guys may be on the beginning of the
track that could one day figure out how
to do that to get into the brain to get
an image out and matches against spectra
or something but I don't know I mean the
subjective prison is really really hard
to break out subjective yeah and I think
even if you started poking around with
microelectrodes and recording the
activity of neurons you still wouldn't I
mean you'd say okay that cell that's
firing action potentials now what does
that look like to you and you'd say red
what is this a problem you don't so that
I think we're never gonna get it never
never help okay never say never but you
know I read a really interesting article
recently I think it was the New York
Review of Books by a philosopher named
Galen Strawson and basically he had a
really interesting take on the mind-body
problem he just turned it on its head
and said you know what consciousness
isn't mysterious what's mysterious is
the physical world so like we we um you
know he says and I think yes there's
something to be said for this we don't
really understand the physical world and
that's why we don't see how
consciousness can emerge from it and you
know he points to the fact that you know
quantum physics is really weird and you
know I think was it fine men said you
know if you really understand quantum
physics then you are totally confused by
it or something to that effect right so
um yep so I think I I don't think our
humble human brains wonderful as they
are well-adapted as they are to all the
things that we have to do in life from
like negotiate the physical world to use
language to develop social relationships
I don't I think they can do a lot of
great things but I don't think they're
ever gonna understand how consciousness
in that red/green sense emerges from
networks of neurons very quickly before
we get to Q&A we just have ten minutes
left to get a questions from around the
planet talking about a new planet
consciousness because we have them on
our iPad here from people who've been
watching live all over the planet and in
this auditorium mm-hmm of the three of
you who have not just been talking do
you all agree with what she just said in
general about the the permanence of the
subjective prison or you have we are you
doubt it or joy or do you not know well
the most truthful answer is of course
that I don't know I mean this is clearly
what's been called the hard problem in
in neuroscience and the hard problem is
how does my subjectivity compare with
yours I
I like the gravity comment that and it
is related to your notion that what
consciousness really isn't as important
to understand as the outside world and
that is how we perceive the outside
world and how we perceive others is
perhaps the hallmark that we're
interested in you know when in science
when we when we take on a problem like
say we want to understand consciousness
usually we have an idea of what the
answer looks like and I think that
that's part of our problem here if
consciousness stared us in the face
would we know it would we know if we
really have the right answer if there's
an it there and and I'm not sure we
would and Sue and so I think that maybe
studying that the physical world might
be a faster route to consciousness and
maybe someday consciousness to come
knocking on our door and some data will
say to us hey I'm consciousness you've
missed me all along I'm a little more
optimistic I think we might change you
know we when we find the answer it might
be because we've changed the question a
little
but I think the you know yes we're in
it's in the infancy there's a lot of
things we don't know but the promise has
been amazing at the same time so I think
I think I think there's reason to think
that we run will understand a great deal
about how these subjective phenomena
right I really want to echo that I think
it's actually an easy problem in the
following sense of all the things we've
studied biologically this is one where
we're really getting very close to being
able to say this is the exact neural
process that makes a difference between
being conscious or not we also
understand why studying that process
doesn't fully feel explanatorily
satisfying so we have stories about that
too but the main thing is if you want to
know which are the mechanisms of
consciousness in the brain we're pretty
close to an answer if you ask how does
culture affect the brain how do you cure
racism in the brain those are things we
don't know those are really hard
problems they're big complex
multifaceted problems I think we should
stop worrying about consciousness maybe
and turn attention to those indeed and
when we ask the question can you define
consciousness we're asking for a verbal
answer to a verbal problem but it may
not be a problem then Tom Nagel says
just one of the basics of the universe
all right so we're gonna take we're
gonna go over by about four minutes
you'll really have six years set up I
want to take ten minutes to answer
questions from around the planet to
expand our sense of self in some way
here's a question from I don't know
where on the planet if there was an
exact clone of someone with the exact
same brain would they still have the
same mind would they be the same self I
think I know the answer if there was an
exact clone of someone with the exact
same brain would they still have the
same mind would they be the same self
for no more than a nanosecond I think
the answer from what you all have said
is no is there wouldn't be the same self
if there were two different people there
they're in different places they're
experiencing is it am i right it's gonna
say something similar that it depends I
mean what they mean by the question do
they have the exact same experiences the
full replication of the brain with its
memories and identical experiences up to
that moment yes same brain means
you know same traces of experience its
embedded right yeah exactly you know in
that case I'd say that for a moment but
very soon they're they're in two
different places they're not getting it
right back you had you put them in two
different rooms and it's no longer the
same brain I guess unless you feed them
by artificial means the same virtual
reality or something I think I'm
unbelievable science fiction novel that
has a lot of fun was exactly that
pretext called mind scan by Robert J
Sawyer all right well so here's another
question from somewhere on the planet I
don't know anything about the person I
presume it's a human can't be sure these
days is the rise in digital
communication affecting our signaling to
others if some of you done work on this
I just wanted to bet on this question
because I am a lot of what I do in
addition to memories about learning and
I get question I was a kid at a
particular age where a lot of other
parents asked me you know and panic is
it true that my kids using their iPad
it's changing their brains and the
answer is obviously yes because
everything we do is changing our brain
so it what if you find out about whether
it's bad it's changing the bad or
diminishing way yeah I think that we
don't know but that's because it's very
hard to know for anything I mean Jesse
earlier before this panel gave a great
example of addiction right that
addiction can be seen in a particular
context is really bad undesirable thing
but if somebody chooses to pursue it or
drug use I should say for any particular
reason it might be a goal in of itself
so I I think one of the interesting
things we don't have time to elaborate a
whole lot on is that there are these
then the neural perspective is not about
judging the behaviors that emerge it's
about understanding what happens in the
brain to support them a lot of things
you can look at is both good I've got it
I mean we haven't even begun to ask
whether what you're just what you're
studying can begin to explain to us
whatever the word intelligence might
mean you're all nodding in other words
that's a big question
all right from around the world from
someone on Twitter somewhere I would
like the panel to talk about what
neuroscience has to say about
determinism and freewill and how that
relates to the self the old freewill
question and how does that relate to the
quest
what does neuroscience have to say about
any of this I mean insofar as the claim
that you know all of our behavior is
determined by the brain you know it
insofar as the brain is a deterministic
physical system then yeah the
neuroscience view of people is a view
that our behavior is all determined and
therefore freewill makes no sense we all
what freewill makes no sense I mean real
makes no sense yeah I mean you know
don't shoot the messenger I'm just
saying that's coming up it makes no
sense there's no free will involved
anything
we're just billiard balls bouncing
around on a table and I'm sorry
you're smiling you know I just can't
accept this because I can't accept this
myself doesn't like this idea I
suggested Lee it doesn't subjectively
where the thing doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense to us but so so all
three of you neuroscientists who look
into the brain all day joy free will
make sense to you well I I don't I don't
have any data in my hands as an
individual I like to think that I'm in
control but I'm not sure that the data
that I have is in neuroscientists ass
answers one way or the other and the
microbes who were using us to walk them
around me in fact be in charge yeah
that's right yes I mean I think the
freewill debate is another one where
we've gotten very obsessed with this
maybe it's the kind of Western
individualism of session we're obsessed
with this total control can I determine
my behavior I think the anxiety that we
don't have free will is based on a false
pretext and the pretext is that without
free will we can't hold people
responsible without free will we can't
change those are find them
we false claims that's interesting you
mean in other words what really matters
is is can we figure out what's good and
healthy and compassionate maybe well
also what do we do when somebody does
something wrong are that should be be
should we hold them responsible and also
who should be held responsible is it
just that body that person that organism
that did this thing or is also the
social conditions that led to that
behavior giving up on free will allows
us to see how responsibility is
sometimes distributed across broader
groups and that's an effective tool not
for being stuck and fixed in human
behavior but an effective tool for
change by studying how behavior is
controlled we can better understand
human potential human flexibility
something time is different and indeed I
wish Thomas Jefferson was here right now
because we assume that endowed by the
maker that all people are have life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
does that require not does not require
freewill I think that I mean there's a
long answer that question but the short
answer to that question is if we do set
out a series of ideals what is it to
live a good life we have things like
positive psychology that study human
flourishing human well-being
to achieve that isn't about having
freedom in the sense of this
metaphysical ability to control your
faith it's about social capacity to
create a form of governance that allows
humans to live better than they're
currently living and we're pretty far
from those goals we are but the new
neural net may help us the web world may
help us get closer to them and this
comes very close to something that's
central compassion in the end it's
possibly always about it at the very
least survival because we know this kind
of behavior with compassion helps us
survive as a species because we don't
suffer a lot and dialogue and
concentrate on bad things and feel like
not wanting to live so there may be some
survival advantage God's Darwinian
tautology you might call it first to see
that life is good and go on we have to
figure out how to be compassionate and
want to go on living which is not
unrelated to this question asked
from Twitter somewhere on the planet can
you talk about what parts of the brain
are activated while experiencing
compassion and experiencing a sense of
more morality our brain scientist we'd
like to take what parts of the brain are
activated while experiencing compassion
and experiencing a sense of morality I
think is if that person were here I
would have turned that question with a
question so there have been studies that
have done sort of brain mapping of
social cognition when you're thinking
about others when you're judging others
when you're experiencing positive
feelings versus negative to particular
regions but I think what I'd want to do
is really ask the question and return
and say why is it important to
understand those regions particularly
and I think the the reason is you know
that was driving that question is this
idea I think that if we understand where
something happens we understand how it
works and I think that's a really good
first pass that's kind of where we were
ten years ago but I think what we really
want to understand is what else are
those areas doing what do those neurons
do what are they connecting with because
that same map that one would see in the
brain for compassion and social
cognition overlaps often with gold
pursuits and other kinds of functions I
think one of the fundamental things to
keep in mind when we think about brain
mapping is that it's not one part of the
brain never does one function there's
not a compassion center and of it in in
the brain Wow
there's a maintain I've heard all that
for this whole time is you're finding
that any one part of the brain does a
bunch of things is connected to a lot of
other things right i mean that is
specialization absolutely but it's not
specialization that necessarily Maps our
terms so the part of the brain doesn't
solve the problem that can it's the
connections between that part of the
brain and other parts of the brain I
want to back nothing up on this but with
the additional comment that I think one
of the things is really interesting here
is the study of individual differences
certainly with respect to a trait like
compassion
or empathy for example we all differ a
great deal some people are very
compassionate and very empathetic and
others will not so much and so one of
the things that's very difficult to
explain from questions like what part of
the brain does this is why are we so
different and and they've been nuances
that some lead to our individual selves
I think is part of that part of the
answer here that yes there are certain
major systems of the brain that are
engaged when we're empathetic or
compassionate but it's executed in many
different ways in many different brains
in many different times and that's where
the fascination is partly just at the
beginning of a whole new world the doors
are opening up one last question for
around the world dinner out of time but
don't worry our panelists will be
available in the lobby for a few minutes
to ask a few more questions from this is
from Twitter don't know what continent
or or boat or plane this question comes
from what is the connection between
illness like PTSD and the experience of
memory and consciousness can you can
your brain be then rewired it in on a
memory angle with someone else once it's
a again could be a whole kind of
hour-long conversation the very short
answer is that that's something we
understand some things about and people
with a smaller hippocampus you mentioned
have a greater propensity for PTSD and
in some preliminary experimental work
people have shown that you can exploit
the fact that memories change to start
to rewire traumatic memory and you can
see this in the brain it really isn't
your neuroimaging you can see this
effect there has been most of the
important work was developed in animals
with pharmacology and people like Liz
Phelps who's here at NYU have used that
approach to try to create a very you
know simplified model of creating a
negative memory and then rewriting it
but and figuring out what the
parameters are how we can rewrite within
how within how much time of when the
memory was created and so forth but it's
definitely related to the hippocampal
wiring there's a compositor it'll be
helpful answers so quick question for
each of you and we're done sort of
filling the premise of our title your
quick short definition if you have one
if you don't don't be ashamed to say of
self I am I values the self the self is
the set of our deeply held values the
self is the set of our deeply held
values yes the values that connect us to
to others who are like-minded wow I'm
not sure there is a self in the way
we've been talking about it just
question is it a verb or a noun is self
a verb or a noun
um you know if if myself we mean
something that does endure over time
some essence of a person that makes them
the same person I'm kind of with David
Hume I guess and Buddhists and various
others no I'm not sure there is such a
thing although I admit that we certainly
have the intuition there is that there
is right part of the subjective prison
perhaps I say you know that we are what
we've learned from our learn then we
remember from our experiences but with
it with the specification that that's
reflected more in what we actually do
that defines who we are rather than what
we're what we who we think we are more
towards verbalization thank you joy I'd
like to turn the question upside down
and think of myself as what other people
think of me so I'm just think about well
in three or four minutes the most these
good folks will be in the lobby to
answer a few more questions I think
there's nothing but not a blown mind but
a blossoming mind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]